[موسيقى]
اعتاد اهل قريه ان يقدموا لملكهم في يوم
ميلاده اجمل الهدايا وانفاسها الا فلاحا
فقيرا ما كان يملك من المال ما يسمح له
بشراء هديه فقرر ان يقدم اغلى ما يملك
طائر الكونو في القصر ساله الملك عندما
وضعه بين يديه ما ميزه هذا الطائر اجاب
الفلاح انه مذل في الصيد فهو يغرد مناديا
بني فصيلته واذ يلبون نداءه يقعون في
الافخاخ التي انصب لهم غضب الملك مما سمع
اخذ الطائر من عنقه وقطع راسه فهو لا يريد
في مملكته من يخون قومه حتى لو كان حي
الى
العناوين هولندا ليست مستعمره اسبانيه
بفضل قمصان العثمانيين وسراويل
نائب مصري يطالب بفرض ضريبه على تجاره
المخدرات الاسد يمنح جبهه النصره جائزه
اوسكار العالميه
ويهنئ كاظم فنجان يضرب من جديد مطار دولي
وسفينه
نوح ابو الشهداء يهدد ابو الليل باكله ومن
معه اذا دخل
بنغازي الهباش لثوره انسانيه على اسرائيل
وضد حماس على
الجثث معارض مغربي نؤمن برساله الصحافه
فنتركها
تنبح مرحبا هل تساءلتم يوما ماذا كانت
تغني السيده ام ادولف لطفلها هتلر حتى
ينام والده نيرون هل ذبحت لابنها طير
الحمام الحجاج هولاكو ستالين ميلوسوفيتش
بوش شارون شامير جولدا مائير هل كانت لهم
اسماء دلع طفوله جولدا جلل هولاكو هلوك هل
كانوا يضحكون وهم نائمون وكيف كانوا يفون
في الاحضان
بالتاكيد بعض الامهات ظلمن بمستقبل
ابنائهن فيما بعض اخر كنا يكتبن بيمينه
عند كل هزه سرير شهاده وفاه الوف الضحايا
والمساكين
[موسيقى]
يا
مو اشرب من دمات يا مو يا
مو يا
مو دمر لهم حياتهم يا مو يا
مو اشرب من دمات يا مو يا
مو يا
مو دمر لهم حياتهم يا مو تعبت كثير يا
مبيت
ربيتك حتى نزعت الرحمه من
حياتك تعبت كثير يا مبيت
ربيتك حتى انزعت الرحمه من
حياتك حافظ على عرشك وكرس
تك حتى لو حرقت بيوتهم يا مو يا
مو يا
مو اشرب من دمات يا
يا
مو يا
مو دمر ل حياته يا
مو هذه ام هنادي قائده ميليشيا مسلحه في
الحشد الشعبي العراقي علقت على تصنيفها من
قبل هيومان رايتس وتش كمجرم حرب بانه شرف
لها ان تكون مجرمه على خطا هتلر اناي
اعتبره هذا الشرف ووسام الي ان اكون قائد
ميليشيات في الحشد وان اكون مجرمه حرب لان
هتلر نال المرتبه الاولى في ان يكون مجرم
حرب في المقابل نزع ملايين البشر هذا
الاسبوع صفه الامومه عم من تستحقها فقد
تابعوا فيديو دخول طفلين الى غرفه والدهما
اثناء حلوله ضيفا على بي بي سي وحكموا
مسبقا ان السيده التي هرعت لسحب الطفلين
هي خادمه العائله وليست الام فق بسبب
ملامحها الاسيويه وهو ما اشعر الزوجين
بالم
شديد وفي اسبوع الام قبله وفاء اطبعها على
يد امي وعنها لامر جميع الامهات الصالحات
حول العالم تسع شهور وانت
حاملتين مادا تعبت كثير ت
جبتيني وعذبتك كثير
تربيني وضاعت التربايه فيني يا
ابو يا
امو يا
م يا ست
الحلال يا
[موسيقى]
م ما ستشاهدونه الان ليس في بلد عربي قمعي
وليس في كوريا الشماليه بل صور في البلاد
الواطيه كما هو اسمها ليبيي با في هولندا
الشرطه مع كلابها البوليسيه ج الى جنب
تقمع بالضرب وبعض تجمعا لرعايا اتراك
رفضوا بطريقه سلميه قرار السلطات طرد
وزيره الاسره التركيه ومنع وزير الخارجيه
من دخول هولندا للمشاركه في فعاليات
ترويجيه للاستفتاء التركي حول توسيع
صلاحيات رئيس
الجمهوريه هل اصبح وجه هولندا يشبه
التقاسيم الحاده لوجه رئيس الحزب اليمني
المتطرف فيها خيرت فيلدرز الذي يرد طر
المسلمين واقفال المساجد ومنع القران
والحجاب والذي سبق ان وجه رساله طائفيه
للشعب المسلم في
تركيا
tures
all for freedom democracy human rights
are incompatible with islam turkey voted
for erdogan a dangerous islamist who
raises the fl of islam
وفي الشارع الهولندي مسيره لليمين المتشدد
تشوه الصوره التاريخيه للاتراك فضلا عن
قيادتهم
[موسيقى]
الحاليه البدلات العسكريه العثمانيه التي
خرون منها اليوم ما كانت هولندا لتبقى على
الخريطه لولاها ولولا المساجد التي تعلم
فيها جد مولود جويش اوجلو السلطان سليمان
القانوني قيم الاسلام في نصره المظلوم
واغاثه الملهوف عندما وصل الغزو الاسباني
الى اسوار هولندا استنجد ملكها بالسلطان
فارسل له 40 قميصا عسكريا من بدلات قوات
الانكشاريه العثمانيه يلبسها لمقدمه جنوده
فتراجع الاسبان بمجرد ان اعتقدوا بان
الجيوش العثمانيه تساند هولندا الا يستحي
ملككم من طلب نجدت وسيسي حفيد مارك روتيه
وبيرت كونيز الادب مع حفيد جويش اغلو
وحفيدتها فاطمه بتول سيان كايا في القرن
ال1 ولكن يا سيدي نحن الان ما زلنا في
القرن السادس عشر وكيف ف نتجاوز ما
تناقلته مئات المواقع
الالكترونيه من اخبار فيها اهانه
لاحفادنا يا عثمان اعطني الايباد الايباد
نعم نعم
الايباد هولندا تصاعد بوجه
تركيا الهولنديون يفرقون الاتراك هل اتابع
ويل لهذا الجني من اين اتاك بالاخبار هذه
الاخبار ستحدث بعد مئات السنين هذا يعني
انكم لن تساعدون بسبب تنكر احفادنا بل
سيساعدكم ليس لانكم
تستحقون ولكن لان نصره المظلوم واغاثه
الملهوف من
قوانيننا عاش مولانا السلطان وعاشت
السلطنه
العثمانيه ترسلون من المقاتلين مقاتلين لا
لا ضروره
للمقاتلين سنعطيكم 40 بدله من لباس قواتنا
الانكشاريه تلبسونها لجنود في مقدمه
المواجهه مع الاسبان وتنتهي
[موسيقى]
المشكله مولانا سلطان مولانا السلطان
مملكه هولندا تشكر جلالتكم فقد فار
الاسبان من المعركه عندما راوا طلعتنا
ببدلات جنودكم ويرجو اخوكم ملك هولندا ان
ترسلوا لنا بعض احذيه جنودكم يتقوى بها
على الغزاء
وشكرا لماذا تصاعد هولندا وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه في وجه تركيا انها لعنه
الفراعنه على اردوغان فقد استيقظ رمسيس
رانيا ياسين يعني الدنيا كلها منقلبه عليك
دلوقتي يعني انت الفراعنه بقى
معلش اسفه يعني ورمسيس التاني لسه طالع
[موسيقى]
لنا بيقوللك ان المنطقه دي كانت مليانه
اثار تماثيل صغيره وذهب وياقوت والكلام
فبعد ما اتسرقت يعني ابتد بقى الكشف عن
هذا التمثال تامر امين لا يستعمل سحر
الفراع للشر بل رد فوز برشلونه الكاسح على
باريس سان جيرمان الى ما وصفه بالطاقه
الفرعونيه التي استمدها ميسي بعد زيارته
مصر وده تاثير زياره ميسي للهرم وابو
الهول عشان تعرفوا ان الفراعنه لسه سرهم
باتع طيب هذه الطاقه لماذا لا تساعد فريق
مصر القريب قبل الغريب لماذا لا تتدخل
الفراعنه في ازمه الزيت والسكر بدل تعنيف
الناس وشتمها كما فعل اللواء المتقاعد
محمود منصور في استعراض اعلامي عايزين
كيلو زيت الزيت غلي الزيت ولع السكر يا عم
ما انت عندك 5 كيلو زيت في الدولاب عندك
ولا في النمليه ههم لازم يبقوا 10 كيلو
زيت
ايه دي قله حايه دي قله حايه ما تتسم حاجه
تانيه ها دي دفعت ابنها ا ادفع جوع ادفع ق
عشا دي دفعت ابنها عشان نعدي والا مصر مش
هتبقى موجوده مصر هناك من يطالب بتخفيض سن
الجنديه الى عمر الثلاث سنوات يعني طفل
عمره ثلاث سنين لازم يلتحق بالجيش الخبر
ما بيتصدق بس في فيديو وصاحب الاقتراح
طبيب نفساني يعني سلموه المرضى يعالجهم
اندخل اولاد الجيش من سن ثلاث سنين حخش
يضرب تعظيم سلام ركزوا معي منيح في هذا
الخبر لان الموضوع خرج عن السيطره نائب
مصري وعضو في لجنه الموازنه اسمه بدير عبد
العزيز يطالب بفرض ض رائب على تجاره
المخدرات اعتبره متهرب من ضريبه ارباح
تجاريه عن حجم نشاطه في المخدرات في المده
اللي سبقت الضبط عليه اذا سعادتك انت حطيت
التاجر كده زيه زي صاحب شركه هرب من ضريبه
يا شيخ المخدرات يجب تجريمها وليس قونن
تها تفضل شوف ايش صار بمجلس تلاوه مع احد
المقرئين
[موسيقى]
و
[تصفيق]
بنا الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر ربنا
يحفظك يا رب ربنا يحفظك يا رب يا اخي حرام
عليك يا اخي لسه يا اخي لسه يا اخي لسه يا
اخي والله والله لسه والله العظيم لسه
والله لسه
البسمله اللي بتخش في النغاشيش البسمله
اللي بتخش في النغاشيش
والله العظيم اسعد اعلى
س
البسمله الاعلامي عمرو اديب دخل المستشفى
للعلاج نتمنى له الشفاء وقد بدا بالتحسن
بعد اتصال الرئيس السيسي به بحسب زوجته
الاعلاميه لميس الحديدي التي اكدت ان كل
اجهزه الامن استخبارات اتصلت بعمر
للاطمئنان عليه ولازم اشكر سياده الريئس
علشان هو اتصل بيه شخصيا وعرضوا كل حاجه
والله يعني سواء يعني القوات
المسلحه
الرئاسه الجهاز المخابرات كل الناس
اصدقائنا ريهام سعيد وبكل جراه تشيد
بالسلطه
وبمخازن
في بقكم لا
نظم استقبال انجلا ميركل ده الرئاسه يبقى
خلوا الرئاسه هي اللي تعمل كل حاجه بعد
كده وتحطوا لسانكم في بقكم لو الجيش هو
اللي منظم لو المخابرات هي اللي المنظمه
يبقى احنا اللي مبوظين الدنيا يبقى هم
ممكن يعملوا لنا شوارع كويسه واحنا مش
مدينهم فرصه احنا ولاد كلب احنا بنداق
زعماء وبنتن
[موسيقى]
عليهم قدم الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد من
جبهه النصره بخالص التهنئه بمناسبه فوزها
بجائزه اوسكار فان فريق الخو البيضاء
للاسعاف الذي حصد الاوسكار الوثائقيه هو
فرع للنصره بالنسبه
للاسد
[ضحك]
النصره القاعده ان اوسكار لو كنت مكان
بشار الاسد شو بتسوي سؤال طرحته كاميرا
وكاله شهاب على السوريين في مدينه دوما
المحاصره كن اقل شي حفظت ميت وشي وتركت
هالبلد هلا اول شغله في شعب من حا بده قصف
اللي هن التجار كنت دشرت ومشيت بالثقيل
كرمال الوطن كرمال البلد هي تبع كاميرا
خفيه طيب لو كنت مكان وزير النقل العراقي
قاظم فنجان ماذا تفعل
تحول كل ورش السيارات المستعمله الى
مطارات دوليه فنجان يثير زوبعه جديده من
السخريه بافتتاحه مطارا في خيمه عسكريه
مدعيا ان المدرج كان منطلقا لسفينه نوح
عليه السلام سوف نقوم بترتيب رحلات
اسبوعيه بدايه كل يوم جمعه تنطلق من بغداد
نحو الناصريه استغفر الله يا ربي والكم
معقوله هذا ما طار قاعده عسكريه بالتاكيد
هناك مطارات سوف تتضرر مطار كويت سوف
يتضرر مطار دبي سوف يتضرر من هذه النقطه
هذا مدخل جراج مدخل ممكن علوه مو مطار
دولي خيمه عسكريه مالت جنود هي هاي صاله
الانتظار مال المطار المدني يعني انتم
مصدقين هذا مطار جانب من الاحتفالات
بافتتاح المطار سيارتين اطفاء واحده ضاربه
مي هيك والثانيه
مقابلتها ومسوي قوس النصر او قلب الحب
والطياره فايته من جو قلب الحب هل اذكركم
ب ملحم قلقاش عندما قال يا بيت يا ابن
اوبار نونو يا بيت القصب اهدم بيتك وشيد
زورق من هنا انطلقت اكبر شبن العالم
يقودها سيدنا نوح عليه السلام وتراهن
وياكم اذا نزلت طائره بعد طائره الوزير من
الركاب
عاتبوني من الاضرار التقليد للفاصوليا
الغثيان والنفخه وتشنج القصبات الهوائيه
لكن ضررا جديدا سجل في مختبرات العراق
فاكله الفاصوليا قد تسبب الطلاق وتحرك
قطعات من الجيش العراقي لسحب الزوجه الى
منزل اهلها خلاف بين رجل وزوجته بسبب اكله
فاصوليا على ما يبدو لم تعجب الزوج استدعى
تحريك قطعات عسكريه في منطقه جنوبي بغداد
للتدخل واصطحاب الزوجه الى بيت اهلها بعد
ان اتصلت بشقيقها وهما ضابطان في اللواء
الرئاسي الجيش هل وجد مكافحه الارهاب او
وجد الخلافات العائليه واذا اخوانها ضباط
بلواء رئاسه الجمهوريه يستخدمون صب بتهم
العسكريه يجون ياخذون المره
[موسيقى]
ويروحون نداء الى ابو الليل في ليبيا اذا
عدت الى مدينتك بنغازي فان صالح رجب سوف
في ياكلك باسنانه انت ومن معك وقد اعذر من
انذر فكيف يصح لابو الليل وهو مختفي في
مصراته ان ياتي الى بنغازي ساكله واسرته
ومن
معه الاسبوع المغاربي سجل اكثر من لقطه
غير مالوفه تتعلق جميعها بالاعلام
والاعلاميين في المغرب سئل رئيس الحكومه
المكلف عبد الاله بن كيران عن تعثر تشكيل
الحكومه فكان جوابه حشوم عليك جاي تعك علي
الجو كلمه حول تشكيل
الحكومه ما حشومه عليك جاي تعكر عل الجو
يلا سير عند المعارضه المغربيه الوضع ليس
افضل حالا هذا زعيم حزب الاتحاد الاشتراكي
ادريس لشكر وفي معرض هجومها على صحيفه
محليه اكد انه يؤمن برساله الصحافه لذلك
يتركها تنبح ولم يتساءل يوما عليش ما عم
مره م رفعنا هذه الدوى قد
تركوه لما ينبح به وعليه السلام مسيو
ادريس الصحافه مهمتها نقل الباقع اذا صرح
احدهم تنقل تصريحه واذا نبح احدهم تنقل
نباحه في تونس واثناء تاكيد الناطق الرسمي
باسم الحكومه حريه الاعلام في البلاد نطق
الميكروفون مصدرا صوتا مزعجا فسره البعض
على انه لم يتحمل هذه مبالغه تمسك الحكومه
بحريه الاعلام كمكسب للثوره
[موسيقى]
وان في تونس ولحظه وصوله الى مقر الحكومه
مازح الوزير الاول الجزائري عبد المالك
سلال الاعلاميين فاتهم هم وادواتهم
بالارهاب
ش
ارهابيين محمود الهباش مستشار الرئيس
الفلسطيني يدعو الى مقاومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بكافه الوسائل السلميه
والقانونيه
والانسانيه بمقاومته السلميه بتشبهنا
بالقانون الدولي وبحقوق الانسان
سنتحدث لن
نسمح مؤامره دويله غزه او اماره غزه ان
تمر الا على اجسادنا ولن تمر حتى على
اجسادنا يستغرب البعض لماذا يركز الهباس
هجومه على حماس ويغفل عن حركه محمد دحلان
التي تشكل التحدي الاول لقياده السلطه
وفتح في الوقت
الراهن رئيس الوزراء الاردني هاني الملقي
كان يلقي تصريحات عن رؤيه الحل للقضيه
الفلسطينيه خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع
نظيره التركي فتعثر ثم تعثر ثم مشي الحال
انء الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله على
حدود الرابع على
حدود على حدود
1967 بحيث يتمكن الفلسطينيون
والاسرائيليون الى اقامه الدوله
الفلسطينيه
تستطيع الفلسطينيين اقامت دولتهم على هذ
على هذا
الارض بسيطه تعثر الملقف الكلام النائبه
الاردنيه زينب زبيد طلعت عن النص والمضمون
والتاريخ والجغرافيا فهنا احمد الدقامسه
بخروجه من السجون الاسرائيليه بسبب عمليه
نفذها قبل 20 عاما مع ان الدقامسه كان
مسجونا في الاردن انا النائب زين اب سبيد
بهني الوطن وبني اهلي وقرايبي القام اللي
كنت انا بنتهم اللي عشت انا وياهم تسع
سنوات هك برجوع ابنهم احمد دقامسه وكنت
اتمنى انه ما يبقى ها المده الطويله في
السجون الاسرائيليه فيما الطبقه السياسيه
في لبنان غارقه في اعداد قانون انتخابي
يضمن فوزها من جديد كانت شوارع بيروت
غارقه بامطار حولت احد الانفاق الى
اكواريوم سيارات هينا نحن بقلب النفق وه
السياره ش بالماي وهيدا
لبنان هيدا
لبنان ختاما اقتنى ملك عشره كلاب وحشيه
لتلتهم كل متهم بالخيانه او التقصير اخطا
احد وزرائه في تقدير موقف فامر باعدامه
عضا انفطر قلب الوزير وناشد ملكه لقد
خدمتك ع سنوات فامهل ني فقط ع ايام قبل
تنفيذ حكمك وافق الملك فطلب الوزير من
الجند ان يسمحوا له بخدمه الكلاب وكان له
ما طلب اطعمها جيدا واعتنى بها حتى جاء
موعد الاعدام فزج بالوزير في حلبه مع
الكلاب بحضور الملك وحاشيته على المدرج
للاستمتاع بالمشاهده فاستغرب الجميع مما
راوه تجمعت الكلاب تحت قدمي الوزير دون اي
اذى فقال له الملك ماذا فعلت بالكلاب يا
كلب اجابه خدمتها عشره ايام فحفظت ني فهم
الملك قصد الوزير فقطع راسه رات الكلاب ما
جرى فانقضت على الملك وافترس ونفقت الكلاب
من السم الذي
بالملك الى اللقاء لا
تظلمنا اذا ما كنت
مقتدرا فالظلم
مرتعه يغضي الى
النادم تنام
عينك
والمظلوم
منتبه يدعو
عليك وعين الله لم
تنمي
[موسيقى]
l